to 600 years say it again s say it
again if you read in the in the old test
the god of Adam and Eve went onto a
crusade for 6005 generation which is
equivalent to 600 years okay destroying
Nations after Nations and leaving
leaving some of his disciples in each
Nation like what you see happening in
Israel today they're not people well
they are people but not they don't have
they don't have what country way they
they don't there are those that walk
among us that is lacking completely of
any emotion they have no compassion
people they following the Old Testament
that's why I take you look what the Old
Testament mentions about the prophets
and God there's a lot of lies and
against prophet of God and and get good
well they're not they're not fallowing
the Old Testament they're the one that
gave us the Old Testament are following
the Old
Testament no no because the Old
Testament teaches you to kill the Arabs
who are the malachit and to genocide
them and that's what the nanahu the
terrorist is doing in inaz killing
innocent people you know and this the
the problem here we have here in the
world that how come we're not standing
and guess this evil terrorist Netanyahu
who's killing people in Gaza people are
justifying now the Western world are
justifying by saying you know what yeah
the Western World I mention that before
they into hypocrisy how when Isis will
comeing and kill innocent people the
Western World they will call them
terrorist and they are terrorist Isis no
doubt about that and we say that not
because the Western World and who do you
think created them the Western world no
doubt America United Snakes you know the
United Snakes created them anyway likeed
snakes yes okay I'll accept that accept
that United Snakes create them but unit
what I'm saying now they never said you
know what you know these people maybe
they hav reason for attacking us because
we went to Iraq or Syria they will
accepting no justification from Isis
likewise you should not accept no
justification from natyu who is killing
innocent people women and children in
Gaza I think I think one of the things
that we need to look at and try to
figure out or ask a question about this
that from the beginning of this planet
there has always been War there is
approximately there there is
approximately no on about 30 40 Wars
that is not spoken of so so what what do
you what do what what do they achieve by
Wars no there's two type War there's a
blame worthy war and a praiseworthy war
in the Quran there's a praiseworthy war
in the Quran the war was legislated to
remove oppression and establish justice
so to answer your question why there was
a war the war was there to achieve uh uh
justice and remove oppression that's why
in the Quran Allah rebukes those who
indulg in War for the sake of arrogance
the S I'm going to I'm going to leave
you now but I'm going to tell you this
the reason for Wars is to create
suffering and just a sec well I'm just
saying to
you I'm saying this is this is what I
know it creates
suffering and that suffering is food to
some people on this plan you're right I
agree there's some about just told me
that it's it's not true no no there's
two I said I said there a praiseworthy
and a blame worthy not war not all the
wars are for to cause suffering rather
War to remove suffering if you
go well well if if it's if it's to
remove suffering and Islam is so
powerful tell me something why is Israel
allowed to abuse the Palestine as they
do and the Israel and and your don't get
because Prophet Muhammad told us you
know you ask me question to please to
you again objectively what it the truth
what's happening now to our Muslim
brothers and sisters around the world
Prophet Muhammad told us about it he
told us when the Muslims all the Muslims
when we turn away from our religion and
we start following the footsteps of the
Nations before us then Allah will send
down humiliation upon us so what you see
now Prophet Muhammad told us about it
already he said that will happen and
sometimes it's a test because sometimes
Allah will test people by giv of power
to see how they're going to utilize the
power you understand Allah as a man
don't you Allah is not a man no I say
you see him as a man I see who Allah
Allah not a man Allah must be because
you sh that he test us he no in Arabic
language when you use the word he
doesn't mean a man because in Arabic
language no no no I didn't say I didn't
say that I'm saying that you say Allah
would give this you will test that
person you test that person that's the
kind of thing that men does no no no no
Allah does that too I mean if a man says
doesn't mean Allah do it like a man see
and Allah see you have the wrong
perception of God no you do I have it
from God okay okay let me tell you this
what I know about God before what you
know about God where you get it
from I'm not going to say that we get
that's the most important who knows who
knows who knows in the summer in the
summer when I come here again I might be
able to tell I might feel the to tell
you right now I don't
come I don't feel the need to do that
what I what I do know is this in my
heart in my heart this is my perception
of life I believe that all of us can
live a life of Love Peace Harmony and
balance that's I think not in reality in
theory that's what you love what you
like real you got to you go you go to
you go to school to learn education no
no uncle uncle we have to be realistic
that's what Islam teaches you to be
realistic in theory and our dreams yes
everyone together love but in reality
there's many people out there who are
evil who doesn't want to accept people
who have different beliefs who have a
different backgrounds and understand
that so Islam teaches us let me I will
leave you with this because I will have
you studed the history of Islam in Andel
no you know Andel Andalusia Andalusia
where the Muslims ruled Spain and
Portugal and part of France for nearly
900 years so the Muslim they were in
authority and the Christians and the
Jewish people they were under them you
see how they live in harmony based upon
what based upon the Islamic teach you
could not have lived just a second you
could not have lived in harm could just
a second just a second you because you
look if you going to be honest your
religion invaded Spain no no no Mar
never invad Spain cuz now if you go days
a
history he asked do you know Andia said
he don't know it and now you're telling
him that well I know that I know that M
no that's I know that I know that the
British I know that the British after
period of time I think it was something
like that I know
that but I'm not here my interest is not
what you do my all that I'm
interest have no interest have
go do research there's many research
from non-muslim in Spain now there
is you look like I have Spanish
and so what we say to you I'm from North
Africa by the way we all together we W
before Algeria Morocco Tunisia morania
you know the point here that there's
many now many manuscripts discovered
where the the indigenous people of Spain
they were seeking help from the Muslim
leaders and guess the
came the Christians anyway do his take
have a good day
take